the odds of you winning an Oscar are
11,500 21 guilds of you dating a
supermodel or 88,000 21 and the odds of
you becoming president of the USA are
about 10 million to one but there is a
purpose to pointing this out I promise
so the odds of you being conceived to
become exactly the person you are today
that is your father meeting your mother
and the proverbial birds meeting the
bees are about four hundred quadrillion
to one even just sitting where you are
right now may be channel surfing with
one hand and eating cereal with the
other you have beaten incredible odds
it's more likely that all the planets in
our solar system will align all that
lightning will strike someone more than
six hundred ninety four billion times
and even more shockingly it is less
likely than gareth gates ever having
another hit record it's easy to think of
us as only humans and i tend to think so
every day and it's hard not to focus on
the difficulties of life and sundays
question whether it's worth getting out
of bed at all but you right now have
beaten the most immaculate odds being
able to exist right now is nothing short
of a phenomenon and if you can do that
once there's nothing to say you can't
win that Oscar become president or
really achieve anything you truly want
to
you